Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 Zoe herminia Fernández
comenzamos
en noviembre de 2022 miles de jóvenes
chinos manifestaron contra los
confinamientos contra las pruebas pcr y
además para pedir más libertades el
movimiento fue diseminado en unos pocos
días la política cero covid fue
desmantelada pero la juventud china
aprovechó para expresarse a pesar de los
riesgos porque su descontento va más
allá de las medidas sanitarias desafiar
a las autoridades chinas parecía
impensable los confinamientos estrictos
marcaron a toda una generación en edad
de Independencia cientos de millones de
jóvenes chinos tuvieron que aguantar el
encierro las universidades se
transformaron en fortalezas sanitarias
bajo la política cero covid fueron
aisladas del mundo
ahora con el final de esta medida
ciertos jóvenes chinos aspiran a retomar
una vida normal pero muchos otros buscan
la manera de irse porque ya no se ven en
China en un futuro aquí la historia
[Música]
los gritos de descontento de una
juventud china está al borde de un
ataque de nervios contra la estrategia
cero covid e incluso contra el poder
Comunista
[Música]
a finales de noviembre de 2022
algo que no se había visto desde el
movimiento estudiantil de 1989
desafiar así a las autoridades chinas
Parecía impensable un movimiento
espontáneo sin líderes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en menos de tres días el aparato de
seguridad sofocó la protesta
una semana más tarde Beijing desmanteló
su política de cero covid pero las
raíces del malestar son más profundas
en un país en el que la censura impera
donde cualquier crítica es reprimida con
severidad Porque estos miles de jóvenes
están protestando Cuáles son las causas
de este descontento de este desafío a
las autoridades de chillimpín
[Música]
tras las manifestaciones los arrestos se
multiplicaron
los testimonios son escasos
este habitante de Shanghai quiere contar
lo que ocurrió por su seguridad no
podrán ver su rostro
esta manifestación era pacífica y no
hubo desbordamientos de nuestro lado
Pero en cuanto usted se dirigía al lugar
lo detenían enseguida la policía se
llevaba la gente brutalmente todos
sentimos el mismo temor en este momento
aquella noche evitó que lo arrestaran
Pero uno de sus amigos pasó dos noches
en prisión esta represión Relámpago del
movimiento lo desmotivó
Será muy difícil conformar de nuevo esa
resistencia en otros lugares del mundo
es normal expresar su reivindicaciones
pero en nuestro país no se puede
expresar ninguna oposición ningún debate
es posible entonces interiormente me
siento impotente pero de todas formas
quiero luchar un poco
si el joven expresa tales críticas es
porque está desesperado y traumatizado
por el confinamiento de Shanghai durante
más de dos meses en la pasada primavera
en ese entonces sin ingresos tuvo que
dormir afuera durante semanas
estaba en la calle porque antes vivía en
un hotel y no pude pagarlo durante mucho
tiempo entonces me sacaron
afuera vi Muchas cosas que la gente
confinada ni se imaginaba numerosas
personas dormían en los andenes y
escuchaba la gente gritar escuchaba a la
gente decir que quería morir
los confinamientos estrictos marcaron a
toda una generación en edad de
Independencia a cientos de millones de
jóvenes chinos tuvieron que aguantar el
encierro
las universidades se transformaron en
fortalezas sanitarias bajo la política
cero covid fueron aisladas del mundo
en Shanghai entre marzo y junio de 2022
a los estudiantes les prohibieron
incluso abandonar sus habitaciones
una estudiante a quien le protegemos la
identidad nos permitió visitar la
habitación en la que estuvo confinada
este es nuestro dormitorio cuatro
vivimos aquí
Esta es la cama de arriba y los cajones
abajo para la ropa los zapatos y a la
izquierda de la cama el escritorio para
estudiar
cuatro jóvenes en 20 metros cuadrados
durante tres meses
Atendió las clases virtuales en su
escritorio incluso las comidas fueron
entregadas en la habitación solo estas
cortinas sobre la cama le ofrecieron un
poco de intimidad
sentada en esta silla todos los días
frente a Este muro y en este escritorio
la vida me parecía muy monótona y
aburrida
Por supuesto hubo momentos en los que no
lográbamos motivarnos para estudiar y
trabajar y en los que teníamos la
impresión de no tener Esperanza ni
esperar nada de la vida
un periodo difícil para la joven mujer y
sus pares
según una encuesta adelantada por
psicólogos más del 80% de los
estudiantes en Shanghai sufren de
depresión y ansiedad
en aquella época sufría mucho de soledad
y sentía también la angustia de los
otros estudiantes lo único que nos
decían era que resistiéramos para
aguantar psicológicamente dependíamos de
nosotros mismos
criticar estas medidas sanitarias los
expone a sanciones Entonces los
estudiantes confinados en los campus se
encuentran otros medios para soltar la
presión
se puede ver estudiantes caminar en
círculos en cuatro patas otros pasean
animales de cartón una moda pero también
una forma de denunciar lo absurdo de su
situación
con el final de la restricciones los
campus abrieron de nuevo la joven ahora
puede estudiar afuera pero la mayoría de
las clases y los exámenes siguen siendo
en línea
sigue afectada por el confinamiento
debemos mantener ese descontento para
con la justicia y las políticas
irracionales que nos fueron impuestas de
lo contrario no tendremos ninguna
oportunidad de cambiar el futuro
estas ganas de cambio son de una parte
de la juventud de clase media urbana y
titulada el descontento sigue siendo por
lo tanto minoritario pero le preocupa a
un partido obnubilado por la estabilidad
social en su locución de año nuevo
terminó su discurso dirigiéndose
directamente a los jóvenes
los jóvenes chinos deben cultivar su
abnegación para la patria
y Buscar El Progreso
para propagar su juventud y estar a la
altura de nuestra época
pero el sueño chino anda de capa caída
con el 3% en el 2022 el crecimiento es
el más bajo en décadas
[Música]
la economía desacelera y cerca de un
joven chino de cada seis está
desempleado en las grandes ciudades algo
nunca antes visto
tras años de desarrollo fulgurante
incluso las grandes empresas de
tecnología despiden masivamente
xiai acaba de ser despedido por el
equivalente chino de YouTube y no es su
primer despido
tuve tres empleos a lo largo de los
cuatro últimos años en el primero fui
despedida al cabo de dos años y después
más o menos cada año en cuanto los otros
dos
sin salario ya no puede pagar arriendo
alguno en Shanghai acaba de regresar a
casa de sus padres a sus 28 años
startups o gigantes de internet todos
sus antiguos empleadores sufren por la
crisis sanitaria y regulaciones
drásticas impuestas por el gobierno en
de por sí competitivo el sector
tecnológico se volvió inviable según
ella
llegaba a la oficina a las 10 de la
mañana y no me iba antes de las 21 O 22
horas
la competencia era feroz todos
trabajábamos hasta muy tarde para
mostrarle al jefe que éramos productivos
para mantener el trabajo todo el mundo
estaba angustiado
hoy en día gana un poco de dinero
Gracias a misiones puntuales la cantidad
de trabajadores freelance como ella se
ha triplicado en China 200 millones en
2021 una elección mal vista por las
antiguas generaciones
de regreso al domicilio familiar en una
pequeña ciudad la joven mujer y hija
única sufre presión social
mi familia Espera que encuentre un
empleo estable
porque lo que más les importa es que
cuando me presenten a su entorno puedan
decir que cuento con un verdadero empleo
porque un freelance para ellos es como
un parásito da mala impresión
para otros jóvenes el futuro ya no tiene
lugar en China en internet las búsquedas
de inmigración explotaron pero el tema
es sensible para esquivar la censura las
ganas de irse tiene un sobrenombre
Run correr en inglés
en chino el carácter room significa la
humedad pero como en letras latinas
escribe como la palabra en inglés room
es muy práctico para referirse a la
migración y para hablar de las ganas de
partir
Sara quiere instalarse en Canadá con su
novio para preparar su partida se da
máximo un año abandonar china Shanghai y
a sus familiares de parte del corazón
antes del confinamiento de Shanghai ya
había pensado en irme pero no tenía aún
esa determinación como en el pasado
estudia y Viví en el extranjero en qué
consiste una vida y una organización
social normal en el resto del mundo Aquí
tengo la impresión de que el entorno
general está como un barco que está a
punto de hundirse
sus padres son antiguos funcionarios
fieles al partido con ellos el diálogo
es casi imposible
como mis padres son muy conservadores y
tradicionales en su manera de pensar
tienen muchos prejuicios contra los
países del extranjero
les mencioné mis ganas de emigrar pero
no pude explicar en detalle mis razones
porque piensan que ningún otro país en
el mundo es tan bueno seguro como China
su decisión es irrevocable no imagina Su
futuro en China
no puedo ser prisionera de mis padres
toda la vida
No quiero que mi hijo nazca y crezca en
China
pienso que vale la pena irse por el bien
de la próxima generación
para tener un mejor entorno para vivir
desde el final de la política cero covid
ciertos jóvenes chinos aspiran a retomar
una vida normal en su país pero para
Sara y muchos otros Ya es muy tarde
[Música]
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para visitar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]